well you slap the sanctions back on
China the tariffs if things you find
them if you've been building the extra
tariffs if they don't fulfill what they
have the right to do that but what
people don't realize I still have this
there 25% tariffs on China one two
hundred and fifty billion dollars worth
of goods I still have those and by the
way remember they used to say we pay for
it no no China devalue their currency
and they pay for it and we have a great
relationship with China right now so I
don't want to speak badly of anyone but
they are having the worst year that
they've had last year was the worst year
they had in 67 was 57 now it's 67 years
and they wanted to make a deal and we
made a deal it's a great deal now we
have a Phase two deal which will start
at some point but phase one was very
important for banking you know what we
did we opened it up to banking but for
banking for our farmers for
manufacturers it's a great china though
is we have a lot of these deals that
I've made South Korea Japan Japan it's
documented all of them we remember this
they were all kicking in now we didn't
have anything
we had horrible deals or no deal to
Japan do we had no deal we're getting 40
billion that's what this is gonna do for
our economy is gonna be amazing and it's
just now it's just signed a month ago
it's just now can the human rights issue
in China you don't talk a lot about it
but it concerns a lot of your strongest
supporters evangelical Christians
Catholics other people who were really
concerned about human rights I've got a
million people in re-education camps
internment camps Catholics been getting
missiles in their in their pews at
Christmas that had tributes to gee
instead of Silent Night crazy stuff
happening Reagan saw the power of the
moral argument for freedom and married
it to the economic and military argument
for peace through strength can you do
more on that front without damaging your
ability to make future trade agreements
more on the human rights
in line because we're making not good
trade deals were making great trade
deals accountant they do count and when
you say Reagan look I was a big fan of
Reagan but he wasn't heavy into it he
wanted to do certain things he worked
wasn't really heavy into it but he
wasn't also making trade deals he let
Japan come in and take our automobile
market you know as much as I like Reagan
he was not good on trade well he did
trade with the Soviet Union at all we
didn't have a bunch of students from
this so I think we should with Russia I
think we should be I think getting along
by the way getting along with Russia now
that the witch hunt is ended having to
do with Russia now that they spent forty
five million dollars found nothing mr.
president when you look at the
trajectory of your administration the
huge progress on trade credible progress
on dealing with our political foes Isis
incredible deregulation judges you've
done a lot on the economy today we found
out that you know still added a hundred
forty six thousand jobs unemployment
historically low at 3.5% but we do have
a little bit of a stall out on wage
growth which we ran on and we've seen
some 2.9 percent last year one percent I
know over last month but we don't have a
tight labor market if we had a tight
labor market would be seeing real
increases on wages I hear that your team
is planning on advocating more foreign
workers coming in for some of these
high-tech companies I'm very concerned
about that and so is Levin a little bit
yeah we're concerns you ran out of Mary
Lou Dobbs is conservative but I'll say
Lou here's the problem I'm demanding
that Japan and all these companies that
countries that have these massive we
have trade deficits like nobody's ever
seen before I say you got to open up I
call Prime Minister Robby's a friend of
my session so you got to open up more
plants in the United States and they
tell me we want to do what we want to do
if they start opening they can't get
labor we need help otherwise we could
just say don't know labor wages would be
going up wait
not in the high-tech industry we're
seeing a plateauing of three percent and
went up 2.9 percent in the last two
years wages have gone up more than they
have in 25 years but for google why
reward Google Google is working against
you I don't want to reward girls I'm not
a fan all they want is low-skilled
workers are not a fan of Google ok are
great companies ok you didn't run on
bringing more foreign workers and video
foreign workers we have to allow smart
people to stay in our country you
graduate number one in your class at
Harvard you graduate from you ran on
people training their foreign
replacements that you ran against that
you've Americans it's humiliating for an
American worker work for a company for
30 years now it's told you got to train
your foreign replacement is gonna live
in Korea and you're gonna pay me 20 oh
that's different that I would never do
that but we do need workers in our
country and I do want an immigration
policy nobody's been better on
immigration than made by the way we won
the funding for the wall and the walls
been built anyway because I was taking
it out of the military everything else
and now it's easier
we need people I got Foxconn to go into
Wisconsin they have to get people with
this they spent a fortune they built the
most incredible plants I've ever seen in
Wisconsin Foxconn American graduates of
colleges and universities we do but we
don't have enough of them we're not we
don't have enough of them and we have to
be competitive with the rest of the
world too if the companies want to hire
these people and they want to hire
people they can hire for the cheapest
amount because I'm talking about
brainpower they want to hire smart
people and those people are thrown out
of the country and can't do this oh
you're in on America first I just have
to finish if we tell smart people to get
the hell out there's a never-ending
appetite on the part of corporate
America to bring in as much cheap labor
as possible to drive down I have so many
companies coming into this country
you're not gonna have to worry about it
it's always going to be a shortage if
somebody smart sitting in this position
now we have so many
he's coming in from Japan Japan's doing
many car companies China now is gonna
start building a lot of things you know
they haven't been doing it too much we
have so many companies wanting to come
in and they don't have the labor but
coming in we're doing great
our country is doing great our economy
is doing great